there was endless
endless
uh there were endless instances
yesterday during the first day of
questions being asked of uh joe biden's
supreme court nominee judge katanji
brown jackson
uh examples of bizarre
inappropriate and cartoonishly odd
questions asked of her and i'm going to
show you some of them now before we look
at the first one and the first one is
going to be lindsey graham asking the
judge to rate her level of religiosity i
think it's important to understand
that in some general sense these
hearings
are basically a sideshow
99
percent of the time
every senator has already decided how
they're going to vote on the nomination
they've already uh they already know the
answers to the questions that they're
asking and typically you will see
senators from the party that nominated
the candidate the nominee um just throw
what we what call throwing bouquets at
each other praise talk to us about how
great your parents are stuff like that
and then
those in the opposite party will ask uh
antagonistic questions now there are
substantive antagonistic questions an
example would be if i had to say who was
the best republican yesterday in terms
of asking questions it was ben sasse
they were
respectful questions
that seemed material
to the role of being a supreme court
justice lindsey graham marsha blackburn
ted cruz
an absolute and total joke let's start
with the first clip here's lindsey
graham asking what religion are you and
how religious are you
what faith are you by the way
senator i am um
protestant
okay um
non-denominational okay
could you fairly judge a catholic
senator i have a record of i mean the
answer would be judging everyone i
believe you can i'm just and by the way
every republican senator other than ben
sasse
relentlessly interrupting judge jackson
relentlessly this question because
how important
is your faith to you
senator personally
my faith is very important
um but as you know
there's no religious test in the
constitution under under article six
how important
is your faith to you later asking her to
rate her religiosity from 1 to 10.
it's 2022 guys it is 2022 and lindsey
graham is asking this question during a
supreme court hearing
ted cruz making a mockery of the entire
hearing
by asking
about racist babies
do you agree with this book that is
being taught with kids that the babies
are racist
senator
the pause is real
i do not believe
that any child
should be made to feel
as though they are racist or though they
are
not valued or though they are less than
that they are victims that they are
oppressors i don't
believe in any of that now importantly
these are not issues on which
a supreme court justice
normally has to have an opinion i mean
what
it is not really for a lawyer or judge
to determine whether babies are racist
it's not a particular topic i've thought
about too much but if i wanted an answer
to it i wouldn't go to a supreme court
justice
marsha blackburn may be the most
weaponized of all of the republican
senators on the judiciary committee asks
are there differences between men and
women
again
supreme court justice what do you agree
with justice ginsburg that there are
physical differences between men and
women that are enduring
senator
respectfully i
am not familiar with that particular
quote or case okay so it's hard for me
to
okay comment as to what now that was
another theme where republican senators
would say judge jackson
are you familiar with the this book and
then this article about the book no i've
never read the book and i've never read
the article okay which of the two do you
agree with
the entire day
here's one more clip of marcia blackburn
asking can you define
woman
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me
a definition now this is this this rings
very uh hits ho close to home for me
because when i was on the jessie lee
peterson show
in out in california a couple years ago
he asked me to define man he said what
is a man and i said i do politics i
don't i don't do definitions i know this
isn't that i'm not the dictionary um and
it was like this all day now
interestingly despite all of the
qualifications of judge jackson
last night tucker carlson on fox news
was still wondering where
are judge jackson's lsat scores legal
minds
one way to know one indication would be
her lsat scores
the lsat is not a knowledge test it
measures logic and reasoning ability and
no one doubts it's an accurate measure
of those things which predicts legal
skills and that's why top law firms law
schools have long used that test
so how did kintaji brown jackson do in
the lsat so and by the way kentaji guys
i mean listen um for years it's not
kamala it's camilla camella
kamala
etc etc and now in the last day i've
heard from these right-wingers kentaji
which is not her name
catania
and a whole bunch of others at what
point do we wonder whether they're doing
it on purpose and i don't know the
answer um so tucker remains concerned
about the lsat scores humiliation
complete and total humiliation from
these right-wingers and
by every
sensible
estimation
judge jackson will have no problem
getting on the court let me know your
thoughts find me on twitter at dpakman
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video